recently I've been declaring to anyone
who would listen that I am a dangerous
woman now declaring that boldly like
this still feels a bit dangerous but it
also feels right at this time in my life
about to be 77 I have I love when you're
applauded for your age
but I'll take it about to be 77 I
realize I have nothing left to prove
less to lose and I'm more impatient
about everything the true slow pace
towards equality the rise and sexism
racism violence against women and girls
and I'm angry too
at the climate deniers who are stealing
the future from our children and
grandchildren friends we are living in
dangerous times and such times call for
all of us to be more dangerous now what
do I mean by this I don't mean being
feared it's not that kind of dangerous
but I do mean being more fear less I
mean speaking the truth when silence is
a lot safer I mean speaking up in rooms
for those who aren't present especially
those rooms where decisions are made
about our lives and our bodies we need
to be in those rooms showing up for one
another challenging the cultural
construct that encourages us especially
women and girls to compete compare
criticize we have to end
and speaking out against the policies
and the politics that divide us and
diminish our collective power as a
global community of women and the men
and the allies who stand with us
becoming dangerous also means embracing
whatever risk are necessary to create a
world where women and girls are safe in
their homes and at work where all voices
are represented and respected all votes
counted the planet protected and this is
all possible because we're ready for
this we're better prepared than any
generation ever before us better
resource better connected in many parts
of the world we're living longer than
ever women over 65 are among the fastest
growing populations on earth with the
potential for becoming the most powerful
- now what it changed this represents
postmenopausal women like me not that
long ago
we're considered useless our crazy we
were valued for caregiving and
grandmother and I really love that part
but we were pushed aside and expected to
retire to our walking chairs women on
the dangerous side of 60 are not
retiring
we are rewiring making
taking all that we know and have done
and that is a lot to redefine what age
looks like can do can accomplish but
becoming dangerous isn't about becoming
a certain age because at each end of the
age spectrum brave women and girls are
stepping up taking the risk to create
change I became a risk taker early in my
life's journey I had to or have my life
defined by the limitations for a girl
growing up in the rural South with no
money no connections no influence but
what wasn't limited was my curiosity
about the world beyond my small town
beyond the small minds of a still
segregated self a world that I glimpsed
in the newsreels at the one movie
theater in town and a world that got a
lot closer to me when I met miss Shirley
Roundtree my eighth-grade English
teacher from the minute she walked into
the classroom her high heels clicking
she was a woman in charge with perfect
hair signature red lips colorfully
coordinated head-to-toe I wanted to be
her gratefully she became my first
mentor and helped me become me with her
support I got a scholarship to college
the first in my family and landed in a
big state university right in the middle
of two great social justice movements
civil rights for African Americans and
equal rights for women
I joined both with enthusiasm only to
discover that my newfound activism and
my fermenting feminism would often be in
direct conflict with my deeply embedded
need to please and be popular in my
first job as a college teacher I broke
the rules and I encouraged
students to join me in the protest
marches and when I found out that my
male colleague with the same experience
in education was being paid more than me
I mounted a personal protest when my
race was denied with the excuse that he
had a family to support so did I as a
single mom but I dropped my protest to
keep my job today millions of women are
making this compromise staying in their
jobs without equal pay for equal work
and as one of the first women on
television in the 70s I was warned that
focusing on women's stories would limit
my career opportunities and maybe it did
but I got to produce and host
breakthrough programming for women while
at the same time remaining silent about
sexual harassment and listening to
consultants who were hired to advise me
about my appearance become a blonde I
did
lower your voice I tried lower your
necklines I didn't but I did wear those
ugly anchor suits but those scars that
looks something like men's ties and
later in the power positions in media
often as the first or only woman aware
of being judged through that gender lens
high struggles from time to time to find
the right balance between being a leader
for women and not being entirely defined
as a woman leader but today I'm proud to
be known as a woman leader
as an activist advocate feminist and as
a newly declared dangerous woman I'm
carrying less what others say and saying
more clearly what I think and feel and
let me be clear I acknowledge my
privilege and being able to do that to
speak my truth
and to stand here today with this
opportunity to talk to you about women
and power note I did not say empowered I
don't think we're waiting to be
empowered I think we have power what
what we need are more opportunities to
claim it to use it to share it and yes I
know there are women with power who
don't use it well or wisely and who
don't share it I've heard as I'm sure
you have those stories that begin with
the worst boss I ever had was a woman
and we could all name women leaders who
have not made us proud but we can change
all of that with a simple but brilliant
idea that I first heard from a
risk-taking dangerous congresswoman from
New York named Bella Abzug Bella said in
the 21st century women will change the
nature of power rather than power
changing the nature of women from the
moment I heard that
I thought this is our call to action
this is our biggest opportunity and as a
journalist and an activist I've seen
this idea in action
documenting the stories of women on both
sides and long-term conflicts coming
together and defying the official power
to form alliances and find their own
ways to ending violence in their
communities and as an activist I've
traveled to places where it's dangerous
to be born a woman like eastern Congo
where a war is being waged on the bodies
of women there at a healing and
leadership center called city of joy
brave Congolese women are transforming
pain into power by training survivors of
sexual assault to return to their
villages as leaders and at recent
climate summit I've observed women
climate leaders working behind the
scenes out of the public spotlight
making sure that the negotiations toward
global climate agreements continued to
move forward so as we move forward in
our lives and work and we have more
power and influence let's change the
nature of power
by dismantling some of the barriers that
remain for those who follow by
advocating and agitating for fairer and
truer and more equal representation in
every room and at every table now be
warned if you advocate for a woman for
an open position or promotion you could
be challenged with your playing the
woman's card or the race card if
advocating for a woman of color I've had
this experience as I'm sure you have are
you running an affirmative action
program here at PBS ask one of my board
members when as a new president
my first hires as five qualified women
now my affirmative action had been to
ask that the search firm bring me a
candidate list that included the names
of women and people of color who just
happened to be in my judgment the best
candidates for the position as well I
say dangerous women and our allies it's
time to play the woman's card played the
race card play all our cards
[Applause]
not to win the power game but to lead to
better outcomes for everyone and it's
time to to discard that scarcity theory
the one that says there's only room for
one of us at the top so protect your
turf don't make friends our allies
changing the nature of power transforms
protect your turf and to share your turf
and encourages coalition's it builds
alliances it strengthens and sustains
friendships my women friends are my
source of renewable energy so are my
mentors my champions my supporters my
sponsors and all of the ways that we can
and do show up for each other we can
become our sources of renewable power
for each other and along the way we need
to take better care of ourselves and
here I'm not the best role model I don't
meditate I don't exercise regularly but
I do live aerobic ly
[Laughter]
because I believe we can't be dangerous
from the sidelines and there's just too
much to be done so let's use all our
power how about the power of money
let's allocate more of our philanthropic
dollars our campaign donations our
investment funds to increase economic
and political equity and let's leverage
the power of media and technology that
we have in our hands quite literally to
elevate each other's stories and ideas
to practice civility to seek the truth
which is diminishing and is threatening
free and open societies yes we have all
that we need to move our communities
forward and the best thing we have and
what we must remember is to be there for
each other we will move forward together
willing now to take more risk to be more
fearless to speak up speak out and show
up for one another
George Bernard Shaw once wrote that he
believed in his opinion that his life
belonged to the community that the
harder he worked the more he lived and
that he wanted to be thoroughly used up
when he died he went on to write life is
no brief candle
to me but a splendid torch that I have
got hold of for a moment before passing
to future generations I too do not view
my life as a brief candle although I am
burning it at both ends
and I do want it and me to be thoroughly
used up when I die but at this point in
my life's journey I am NOT passing my
torch I am holding it higher than ever
boldly brilliantly inviting you to join
me in it's dangerous light thank you
[Applause]